tu nous as quand même collé au plafond
c'est quand est arrivé avec les épaules
but clair c'était quand même la
révolution la plus totale alors là aussi
quand on ta mère et mesure 1 m 76
avaient les épaules 2010 alors est ce
que c'est c'est ça non non parce que
tout le monde était évidente comment
c'était avant toi si tu dis c'était la
fin du baba quoi y avait eu enfin
c'était ramollo ouais c'est très mal
vécu très exotique sur le plan ça va moi
j'ai commencé à frapper quand les
étranges vie afin d'avoir de monter ma
maison j'ai pris nous donne une
compagnie qui s'appelait café de paris
on était en plein baba en plein folklore
et moi je promotionner à bord parmi la
parisienne
le tailleur noir et ça ne s'était pas du
tout ça mais ça a été ça cinq ans un ami
les robes très bull et enfin bon les
talons au terrain et le retour de la
parisienne je l'avais pressenti café de
paris et puis après j'ai monté ma maison
et puis ça a été les épaules larges
épaules larges si c était le début des
80 j'ai toujours à l'arrêt depuis
toujours j'ai commencé dans la mode
comme ça quand j'étais danseur à l'opéra
du rhin on m'arrêtait dans la rue enfin
pas tellement à strasbourg jeudi à paris
omar était dans la rue pour une loi dont
vous pouvez trouver ce que je partais
laisser la danse qui m'a apporté ce
parce que la danse savoir la présence ou
pas la présence et un impact physique et
c'est aussi un port de tête s'est aussi
tenue donc la danse c'est ça c'est une
construction du corps c'est une
architecture
et puis tout ça fait son chemin sans
savoir quoi toi qui as quand même
révolutionner les choses au début des 80
avec les épaules elle est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la ligne muller tout
simplement là maintenant j'ai
l'impression bomba que tu fais un peu
comme tous les autre sûr que tu fous il
ya un peu dans dans les autres modes
alors tu nous fais ici qu'à delhi tu
nous fais la fri et non non non non le
psychédélique j'étais le premier à la
barre maintenant c'est une remise en jeu
c'est une remise en cause des éléphants
oui et ça m'a coûté assez cher c'est une
saison un peu difficile s'est largement
repris matin ouais largement dont je
n'étais pas trompé non mais ce que t'as
pas l'impression après avoir été de
l'avant me reposer quelque chose de
réellement nouveau
d'un seul coup de revenir un peu en
arrière parce que finalement tu fais
comme les autres maintenant tu fouilles
à un peu dans le passé pour trouver des
trucs non tu sais il ya eu une époque
donc les années 80 ça a été une espèce
de futurisme c'est plus le cas
maintenant
maintenant on est sur autre chose et moi
maintenant mon langage est ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est le retour de la
science au luxe en sus alité l'instinct
de joie du corps animé les lentilles
moralité qu'on essaie de nous voir que
laquelle on essaie de nous faire croire
que j'avais réalité parce que je vois je
ne crois qu'en salle espèce de joie
sable
voilà donc c'est ça je vois pas ce que
ça va se passer
pour l'instant gratuit et psychédélique
ça bien voir avec le passé c'est
particulier car maintenant on est et
psychédélique il ya quatre ans parce que
je savais que ça allait venir et dans
quoi avec les allées et qu'ils vont
vendre des années de s'inquiéter tant
que d'une certaine façon tout est bien
tout l'époque psychédélique ce sera
absolument génial charte est d'accord
avec toi tu fais des films de pub
si on donne 300 mille francs qui fait un
fils de pub bah c'est pas une question
300 mille francs suisses qui était bien
ben on imagine donc le bo reçoit bien et
compte 2 300 mille francs trafic de pub
oui à ce moment là s'il est très bien
les trois cent mille francs ça c'était
pas la compassion la plus importante
tu fais tu fais des films une fois tu
t'intéresses à la cinématographie filmé
par un petit fils jean prat parts de toi
là tu fais des photos seins qui sont
bien des années non vraiment sincèrement
je trouve que généralement sahara gérer
les gens qui sont connus pour quelque
chose quand ils font autre chose du bon
ils font ça mais là franchement c'était
très bien les photos étaient était aussi
étonnant que les dernières étaient dans
l'air pas mal fait des trucs toilettes
mais alors est ce que t'as pas peur que
pendant que toi tu fais tous ces trucs
des concurrents qui font qu'une chose
ils y arrivent mieux que toi toute
l'importance et les feux on a même été
actionnées avec l'iran il doit pas
obligatoirement raisonner comme toi moi
donne à penser que l'important c'est que
tu sois heureux ou alors si les
actionnaires
reste à trouver l'essence est allé sur
le terrain les actionnaires réponse de
l'afrique a confondu devant patrice en
comptant la note d'accor dont l'occupant
d'un livre de photos de bellevue
les amusements à dos à moi